bonjour amis de l'ina
[Musique]
le feuilleton qui me touche beaucoup
c'est belphégor belphégor parce qu'il y
avait juliette gréco et juliette gréco
même quand elle n'est pas dans belphégor
elle me fait un peu peur elle a quelque
chose de venimeux de vénéneux mais je
pense que c'est à cause de belphégor que
finalement beaucoup plus tard j'ai fait
des documentaires de faits divers parce
que c'est belphégor qui m'emmenait versa
williams est là devant le fantôme
coucher et mobiles sur une table je vais
dire le vrai journal alors que monde va
dire aura évidemment loterie cela
raconte c'est son émission parce qu'en
fait ça a créé un genre qui s'appelle le
mélange des genres et qui depuis a été
repris beaucoup à droite et à gauche et
ça ça me fait plaisir de voir que en
gros cela n'existait pas avant et que ça
existe maintenant ça c'est un souvenir
d'enfance
on était en train de dîner si j'ai bonne
mémoire on était dans le jura faudra
imaginer à dîner dans le jura dans les
années 70 tu vois donc ça doit être les
vacances c'est j'imagine
et tout d'un coup il y avait la télé et
l'émission s'arrête
mon voisin
[Musique]
nous interrompons ce film le président
de la république m
président pompidou est mort j'étais
désespérée c'est pas que j'aime et
spécialement pompidou mais pour moi un
président ça pouvait pas mourir
kraftwerk est arrivé en plein marasme du
hippisme
déjà ils sont pas anglais ni américain
ils sont allemands
ensuite ils sont habillés comme des
notaires en province dans les années 50
et surtout leur musique c'est pas une
musique habituelle c'est une musique
entièrement synthétique et je dois dire
que après le look costume cravate que
j'ai commencéà à partir de nulle part
ailleurs et puis dernière du vrai
journal et où il est directement
inspirée des kraftwerk
ça a été une école y compris les
lunettes tout et même le prénom car il y
avait un mec dans le crabe vert qui
s'appelait karl bartos ben07 et
nihiliste punk et cal c'était à cause de
kraftwerk
si on parle de l'eau qui a eu kraftwerk
et puis ya quand même une grande
influence c'est paul meurisse parce que
paul meurice dans la série des monocle
non seulement rit jaune mais tirait
toujours absolument à quatre épingles
voilà un garçon qui n'était pas très
très beau qui avait beaucoup de talent
et qui se retrouve être un des amants
d'edith piaf c'est quand même absolument
fascinant d'imaginer paul meurisse edith
piaf
j'aurais met une petite souris pour voir
un petit peu qu est ce qui pouvait se
produire entre eux j'ose pas les
imaginer faisant l'amour mais les
imagine se parlant etc qu'est-ce qu'ils
avaient tellement rien à voir que ça me
fascine elle s'attachait beaucoup à le
faire participer
les gens qu'elle aimait à son action
artistique j'ai pas de conseil à donner
mais je vous en donne un abonné vous
immédiatement aïnats culte sur youtube
[Musique]